Welcome to The Ultimate Guide to the
future of tech in the fast-paced world
of devops staying ahead is the game
changer join us as we unlock the top
devop skills needed in 2024 from
mastering Cloud architectures to
building security fortresses we are
delving into the vital skills shaping
the tech landscape get ready to untravel
the road map to devop success and set
your sides on the tech Horizon let's get
started number one continuous
integration and continuous deployment
cic CD cicd the backbone of modern
software delivery makes integrating code
changes and deploying them smooth and
fast tools like Jenkins and gitlab take
care of testing Version Control and
deployment cutting down manual work
learning these tools might take a bit of
time focusing on Version Control
scripting and how systems run to get
better at cicd trying Hands-On projects
like setting up pipelines for web apps
or automating testing can be a game
changer number two Cloud architecture
and kubernetes knowing about Cloud
architecture and mastering kubernetes is
a big deal today companies are all about
cloud services and using kubernetes to
manage apps stored in containers
learning these involves understanding
various cloud services and how to use
them to build strong and flexible
applications it also means knowing how
to set up and manage containers in the
cloud environment getting good at this
might take some effort especially
learning about networks containers and
cloud computing Hands-On practice like
deploying small apps with kubernetes or
automating deployments can be a solid
way to level up number three
infrastructure as code IAC with
terraform terraform is a St in managing
infrastructure by writing scripts it
helps set up and manage things like
servers or databases without manual
configurations mastering it means
understanding terraforms language and
managing resources across different
Cloud providers getting good at
terraform might not be too hard if you
get the basics of cloud architecture
doing project like automating Cloud
setups or managing resources across
different Cloud platforms can boost your
skills in this area number four security
Automation and devc Ops keeping systems
secure is top priority and that's where
devc Ops shines it's about integrating
security into every step of the
development process this needs
understanding security principles
spotting threats and using tools tools
within the development cycle to stay
secure getting skilled at this might
take some time focusing on security
practices and how they fit into
development trying out projects like
setting up Security checks in your
development process or making sure apps
are encrypted can sharpen these skills
number five data Ops and AI ml
integration data Ops mixed with AI and
ml is the new thing for smarter decision
making it's about making data related
work smooth and automated and then
mixing that data with AI and ml to make
awesome decisions learning this might
need digging into data processing
machine learning and programming
languages like python r or Scala
projects like building models or setting
up data pipelines can give hands-on
experience in this Fusion of data and
smart Tech before we conclude this
exhilarating expedition in to the top
devop skills needed in 2024 Envision
this the future is a canvas waiting for
your Innovation and expertise to paint
upon these skills aren't just a
checklist they are your toolkit for
crafting the technological future
embrace them immerse yourself in their
practice and let them be the fuel
propelling your journey toward Mastery
in this rapid evolving Tech realm
remember it's not just about knowing
it's about doing dive into project
experiments fearlessly and let these
skills be the guiding Stars illuminating
your path to success thank you for
joining us on this adventure make sure
to like this video and share it with
your friends do check out the link in
the description and Pinn comment if you
are interested in making a career in
Devo staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here